so I am curious because I don't want to
spoil any aspect of the film if you
could actually leave set wearing the
costume uh where is the place you would
most want to go and why I honestly
there's only one place that I would go
which is like a children's hospital I I
don't really the idea of going and
wearing that suit anywhere else I mean
look you know you've gone to concerts
before like you don't wear the band
shirt to the concert particularly if
you're the band so I don't know that I
would want to go and wear anything
that's drawing attention to the fact
that hey look at me I'm Shazam I'm gonna
learn much as amsu that could get a
little awkward unless I'm just gonna go
and blow some kids Minds who would you
know be stoked to meet Shazam in real
life I think that could be a lot of fun
first of all I think you should
absolutely do that because it would be
amazing and second of all
um one of your cast mates mentioned
Hollywood Boulevard and I and I I that
actually could be fun and the concept of
all of you guys going to Hollywood
Boulevard and just pretending and just
having fun hey that's a cool viral
moment but like it would be cool I think
that yeah listen I've had thoughts like
this before I I wanted to go do
um uh d23 I was doing a d23 convention
for some Tangled stuff you're involved
in Disney I know it's crazy right right
uh but I thought it'd be really fun to
dress up like Flynn Rider but like get a
prosthetic nose where my nose was wrong
because if I just had a slightly
different nose a lot of people wouldn't
know that it was me but that would be
kind of part of the fun that I'm
Incognito like undercover bossing it uh
so if we got some prosthetic noses or
things that made it you know that made
us look a little bit different then I
would totally wear the suit and go to
Hollywood Boulevard that could be fun I
heard that you like to play music uh
before a scene you know where you really
play music oh yeah so I'm curious how do
you select the songs that you want
before what scene and is there a lot of
thought process into that so I basically
play the same playlist every day uh well
I switched it up a little bit and I'll
go with some other Spotify you know
pre-made playlists but
my my particular place is just my light
songs playlist it's like 550 songs at
this point it's it's just basically the
litmus test is this if I'm ever
listening to a song and my body starts
to move like involuntarily where your
hips just start moving a little bit of
your shoulders start moving you're like
I don't even feel like I was consciously
trying to do this but okay that means it
goes on the playlist and so that's the
kind of music that I play it's mainly
more upbeat kind of dance pop stuff but
it across the decades you know from the
30s to the 40s the 50s 60s 70s and 80s
90s all the way up to today probably
heavy in the 70s 80s
currently that's those three decades are
the most but it's everywhere so one of
the highlights of the movie is you get
to fight a dragon which is obviously
awesome oh yeah um so I want to find out
when did you first find out you'd be
fighting a dragon and what is it
actually like to film fighting a dragon
uh well I first found out I was fighting
a dragon uh even when they just pitched
me
um when when the team uh pitched me
before the script was even written they
had a they had like a treatment for it
and I knew that we were gonna go with
the Greek goddesses and the dragon I was
like oh my gosh this is so cool
um and then what is it like to actually
film fighting a dragon uh lots of blue
screen as as one could imagine
um some interesting props like you know
there's a scene where I'm like pulling
on his tail where we had like a big
practical
dragon tail but it was connected to
nothing
um and then the rest of it's all ct'd in
you know so that's that kind of stuff
listen it's it's what what's fun about
that is you might not have a real
practical thing that you're interacting
with but you get to utilize your
imagination on really really high levels
like you did when you were a kid I mean
you know you'd run around with nothing
in your hands and you and your body I
mean my buddies would pretend to be
X-Men all the time we had nothing I
didn't we didn't have a fake closely
Wolverine we just pretended to have them
and your imagination is just kicking on
a high level and I I love doing that I
really do hope the film's a huge hit
thank you brother um nice to see you